the pandemic is getting more political
with
every day when you were ill how did you
do
how did you feel it felt pretty bad for
a couple of weeks
but fortunately i didn't need
hospitalization or ventilator
the president wants to show you what a
recovery looks like
and float the idea of postponing
something
set in stone by law in a tweet mr trump
said
with universal mail-in voting not
absentee voting which is good
2020 will be the most inaccurate and
fraudulent election in history
it will be a great embarrassment to the
usa
delay the election until people can
properly securely and
safely vote he doesn't have the power
to do that congress does but almost
certainly
won't go there today the president
chose not to go here the funeral of john
lewis
[Music]
a civil rights icon who fought for
voting rights his entire life
and barack obama delivered a powerful
reminder
that battle is far from over there are
those in power
who are doing their darndest
to discourage people from voting
by closing polling locations and
targeting minorities
and students with restrictive id laws
and attacking our voting rights with
surgical precision
even undermining the postal service
in the run-up to an election
that's going to be dependent on mail-in
ballots so people don't get sick
even the president's republican
colleagues except people need to have
their say on november the third i
understand the president's concern
about mail-in voting which is different
than absentee voting
but never in the history of the federal
elections have we ever
not held an election and we should go
forward with our election in
fredericksburg virginia
there's seeds of doubt already sown
though
this state will see a rise in mail-in
voting because of coronavirus
are you concerned by it i'm very
concerned
because i think there's too much room
for fraud because there is
no really reliable evidence that it's
ever been
enough to affect the outcome of an
election in this country
donald trump has been trailing in the
national polls and after the
worst financial quarter in modern
american history
he found something else to talk about
people i've spoken to
here say they think there will be a big
voter turnout whatever he says
this year though long lines at polling
stations and missing ballasts
have shown a system that will be put to
the test
voters don't appear overly agitated yet
but the results could be complicated
and may well be contested